[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you very much.
Thank you.
I can't believe this.
This is not what we planned.
[ Laughter ]
-Jerry!
-So, these are the jokes here?
This is what I do?
[ Laughter ]
All right.
Doesn't look that hard.
[ Laughter ]
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
Happy Thanksgiving, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You guys are the perfect
Thanksgiving guests --
you stay for an hour,
and you're gone.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's what we need.
Today, by the way,
was the 92nd Macy's
Thanksgiving Day Parade...
[ Crowd cheers ]
...and one of
the coldest parades in decades.
It was so cold,
SpongeBob's nipples got so hard,
they popped the other balloons.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Which could be from
the Carson era -- that joke.
[ Laughter ]
All right, I read that...
this year's parade featured
over 42,000 different costumes,
or, as that's also known,
one Lady Gaga show.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Applause continues ]
And I heard that the parade
had over 1,000 clowns,
and it got creepy
when Macy's said,
"Wait.
We only hired a hundred clowns."
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Music continues ]
"Where are the other clowns
coming from?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Music continues ]
[ Music stops ]
Well, listen to this.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
[ Coughs ]
-I heard about a trend where,
this Thanksgiving,
where people made tiny turkeys.
Yeah, tiny turkeys.
You may know them
by their other name --
chicken!
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Applause continues ]
What? He's ready?
All right.
All right, okay, he's --
I'm hearing he's ready.
He's ready? Okay.
Great news, everyone --
here to finish the monologue,
your host, Jimmy Fallon!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪♪ Hey, hey, hey, hey ♪♪
♪♪ Hey, hey, hey, hey,
hey, hey, hey, hey ♪♪
-Jerry Seinfeld!
Thank you!
-Oh!
-Jerry Seinfeld!
-Thank you.
-Thank you!
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
Jerry Seinfeld,
thank you for covering!
-Thank you.
-Oh.
I've -- I've digested a bit...
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
...and I think -- I think --
I think I'm good to go now,
but if you want, you --
you can --
you can stick around and --
and do the rest
of the monologue with me.
You want to?
-No, uh, I'm good.
[ Laughter ]
-Jerry Seinfeld, everybody.
There...
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
That's what I'm talking about.
That's what friends are for.